earlier today the Vatican did confirm  that during his visit to the United  States  the Pope held a secret meeting with Kim  Davis the woman who went to jail because  she refused to issue marriage licenses  to gay couples and now it turns out she  was not the only controversial person  the Pope met with in private while he  was here yeah the the Vatican just  admitted that the Pope's shared a sub  sandwich with Jared Fogle oh it gets  worse  the Pope signed a recording contract  with Suge Knight his story  the Pope rode a roller coaster with  Robert Durst yeah  hunting lions with that Minnesota  dentist they go  and finally the Pope got a private  comedy show from Bill Cosby I thought  that was  [Applause]